in Germany lawmakers have introduced a
bill that would increase a 19%
value-added tax to all the meat in the
country and in the United Kingdom
Goldsmith's University in London has
banned all beef all burgers entirely in
the name of the planet make no mistake
there are people who want to do the same
thing in America until we all have to
get our protein by eating meal worms and
grasshoppers I love a grasshopper
hello launched this town in the evening
Ashley Byrne is associate director of
Peter she joins us now Peter actually is
in favor of a meat tax well peter has
been an advocate for a meat tax for many
years because of the fact that we
already have similar taxes on products
like soda cigarettes and alcohol for
their effect on human health and we have
a similar tax on products that are
harmful to the environment so when you
look at the fact that the meat industry
or sorry meat consumption is a top
contributor to the diseases killing
Americans like heart disease cancer
diabetes and stroke and it's one of the
primary culprits behind every major
environmental concern whether you're
talking about climate change water
pollution air pollution or deforestation
we think we should be following a
similar similar pathways is that okay I
mean Alexandra Ocasio Cortez obviously
went very big when she launched the
green new deal on the on the bovine
flatulence but you don't actually that
doesn't apply to all animals there was a
survey at the University of Waterloo in
Canada for example that suggested that
using pig methane you could actually use
that as fuel and it would be in fact
more environmentally friendly than
saying natural gas well if we want to
get a real picture of the environmental
impact of the meat and animal
agriculture industry as a whole we need
to look beyond the methane and
and beyond climate change we need to
look at things like air pollution and
water pollution and the fact that
deforestation is happening at an
alarming rate to you know create
farmland for grazing but that's that's
mostly in in Africa and other parts of
the southern hemisphere where they've
got a population explosion I mean
essentially we're reforesting in North
America and the rest of the developed
world we're losing giant chunks of the
Amazon of an Amazon and that is to
satisfy global demand for me and also
again if you look at things like water
pollution right here in the United
States the EPA says that animal
agriculture is deleting culprit behind
water pollution and the reason for that
is clear the fact that the animals
raised and killed for food in the United
States produce 10 times more excrement
than the entire human population in this
country so we really have an
environmental crisis on our hands
because of the meat industry that goes
beyond climate just to go back to that
survey I mentioned the University of
Waterloo for example seems to think that
instead of just leaving it there to run
into the river running alongside the
field which is what you're talking about
that we can actually take that stuff and
power our homes and motor vehicles with
it isn't that innovation isn't that more
likely to be beneficial to the planet
than simply abolishing what's a staple
of the human diet well it's not because
there are other concerns for instance
the fact that we use tremendous
resources water food land to produce
meat and it only yields us a small
amount compared to what we're putting in
the resource waste is incredible and
when you look at the fact that actually
we have alternatives now like the beyond
burger that have the taste of meat the
texture of meat they're delicious and
their impact on the environment is so
much lower why would why would we deal
with these industries that are just
dirty and outdated well not to mention
cruel when we have better options
because it's it's a popular taste you
know you look at the big chains here
Burger King McDonald's Wendy's and
that's the other point here isn't this a
regressive tax that the the people who
like you know arugula on a bed of
arugula are the elites at the fancy
salad restaurants in Beverly Hills and
Martha's Vineyard and that it's the the
man in the street who's getting a burger
at London so this meat tax would be a
regressive tax on the poorest people in
society well first of all the man on the
street is looking for plant-based
options now - which is why restaurants
like Burger King and Carl's jr. are
adding vegan options to their menu but
we also have to look at health concerns
and that's another reason that a lot of
people advocate for attacks on meats
again meat is one of the leading
contributors to some of the top killers
of Americans and the fact is that right
now meat is heavily subsidised and so
the taxpayer is footing the bill for the
poor decisions of people who are
choosing to eat meat even though they
know it's bad for their health and bad
for the environment watch this one
Ashley I saw that fellow at the ballgame
this morning who was holding a burger in
one hand and caught the ball in the
others let's that seem to need a sum up
the situation